welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Bruce Gordon who is tight-assed
Street professor of ecclesiastical
history at Yale Divinity School
professor Gordon's research and teaching
focus on European religious cultures of
the late medieval and early modern
periods with a particular interest in
the Reformation and its reception his
book John Calvin's Institutes of the
Christian religion is one of the
defining works of the Reformation he has
also edited books and written widely on
early modern history biblical culture
Reformation devotion and spirituality
and the place of the dead end pre-modern
culture today we'll talk with Professor
Gordon about his forthcoming book on
huldrych zwingli and the early
Reformation welcome professor Gordon
great pleasure to be here so let's begin
with an overview of your book tell us
about it right well this is a book I've
long wanted to get to hold recurringly
is a fascinating character of the early
Reformation very much an enigma he comes
out of a very humble background born in
a mountain valley goes to be educated
he's a prodigious young youth and
student who becomes a priest and then
ends up in the city of Zurich he's
almost a complete a contemporary of
Martin Luther he's born in 1484 and
lives till 1531 but where he really
makes his name is as a preacher who
accompanies the Swiss mercenary troops
into Italy and he experiences the
horrors of war and battle firsthand and
that experience turns is very much a
religious conversion for him and leads
to an idea that war mercenary service
which is so central to the Swiss in the
late Middle Ages and early modern period
it's a great offense to God and that
they are being punished
for this so the enigma really lies in
the fact that he emerges as this major
figure opposing mercenary service the
corruption and all that fools for flows
from it but then he ends his life in
1531 dying on a battlefield battle in
which he was involved in an aggressive
attempt to spread the Reformation to
Catholic areas so he is this person who
on one hand exposed peace and the and of
absence from war and then the other dies
in a most violent way which makes him
unique amongst the Reformers right right
so um and help us understand what the
Reformation is yes Reformation is this
movement that emerges in the early 16th
century focused very much on Martin
Luther whose 500th anniversary of the 95
theses was marked last year
Luther protests against what he sees the
abuses of the Catholic Church and that
protest which it was with the famous 95
theses slowly evolves into a completely
different vision of what the church
should be Luther argues against the main
ideas of Catholicism in the medieval
period to argue that faith alone is what
saves a Christian that scripture alone
is the authority for this for the church
and that one is saved only by the
gracious gift of God so therefore he
emphasizes this immediate experience of
faith and of the relationship of the
individual to God over against the
hierarchical church the sacramental
system of the church the priestly order
of the church and that inspires a whole
movement which is often rooted in
resentment against the church but
Luther's is a master of the printing
press which has now entered into an age
of maturity and his message is spread
across Europe and that really is the
sort of essence of the Reformation and
swingley is a contemporary and it's
espoused as many of the similar ideas
but it really begins with Luther okay so
of course many people have heard of
Luther swingley not so much so how did
you what led you to write the book
and you know why is it that you think
he's not as well-known as Luther given
that their contemporaries sure my own
experience started many years ago when I
went to Switzerland as a graduate
student I intended to work on a very
different project but while I was there
and in the archives it emerged to me the
most fascinating story was actually the
story of swingley and the emergence of
the Reformation in Zurich where I was
and Basel bear on the other Swiss cities
and I became fascinated by this and I
was very much influenced as I think many
of us are by several books one historian
man named George Potter who wrote this
life of Zwingli in the 1970s that that
inspired me to look more deeply into
this character and it's true as you say
swingley is the lesser-known of the most
preeminent reformers often in the shadow
of loser his contemporary and then of
the successor figure John Calvin
swingley sometimes referred to as the
third reformer and he's the one that we
know least about he there tend to be a
few set ideas that are always said about
him which are well that he was the sort
of disciple of the great humanists
Erasmus that he espoused a kind of
rational Christianity and that most
famously his debate with Martin Luther
over the nature of the Lord's Supper
that swingley advocated a position that
the Lord's Supper is only a memorial of
the Last Supper of Christ it is not as
both the Catholics the Lutheran's would
argue a sacrament in which Christ is
really present it's a theological debate
but Luther and Zwingli divided fiercely
on this and so it swingley if he's
remembered is very much thought as
Luther's opponent in that debate but
there's been very very little work done
over the last couple of decades on
swingley he has been something of the
forgotten figure and why is that do you
think I think because he's so much over
he has many ways the founder of what's
referred to as the reformed tradition
which will become Calvinism will become
Puritanism it becomes you know so
crucial to the transatlantic
Christianity and is still of course
widespread throughout the
world with the growth of of Christian
and Reformed communities in Asia and
Africa is swingley is really the first
figure in this but because so many of
his ideas were taken over by Calvin and
further developed into future
generations he is that figure has been
somewhat overshadowed we tend to think
of reformed Christianity as Calvin and
Calvinism and doing they has somewhat
disappeared so in writing the book did
you come upon any new material that
helped you right there look yeah I think
the the the area that has been most
fruitful for me in terms of new material
is something that is not unknown but
very much on mind and that has been his
extensive collection of letters none of
which have been translated into English
so you're reading them in Latin and
you're reading them in the sort of the
German of the sixteenth century which is
a distinctively Swiss German so they're
not easily accessible but there's a
large body of these of this
correspondence and what I have found in
working through his letters a very
different portrait of the figure emerges
so tell us about well he's no longer no
longer seen simply as this kind of sort
of rather Stern moralist and you know a
scholar of the Bible but this person who
was had a deep pastoral sense who was
deeply involved in a whole range of
political questions who who was
extraordinarily active in developing
networks across Swiss lands and across
Germany and he spent a great deal of
time we know from accounts of his life
that he would write letters late into
the night and that body of letters tells
us about the way in which he understood
things like friendship his relationship
with people who had similar ideas his
more polemical works against opponents
but he often talks about his family he
often talks about himself and that's
something we don't get by just attention
to the theological tracts or the other
works much more as I experienced was
working on Calvin for the biography I
did of him
the letters really bring out the person
sure so who are some of the people that
he wrote to some of the people that he
wrote - well of course he wrote to
Erasmus that was a slightly ill-fated
relationship he was desperate as young
priests and a young humanist to have
Erasmus approval and he worked through
various friends to have access to
Erasmus either to visit him at one point
but Erasmus was the great figure and to
have an exchange of letters with her
asthma's was the highest Sur accolade
you could you could achieve as a young
aspiring scholar but then in the end
Erasmus turns on swingley when swingley
starts to a dog the more so Reformation
ideas similar to Luther so Erasmus is an
early correspondent he writes to his
cousins he writes to there is a figure
in Basel Johannes Eklund partyís who was
one of the great scholars another even
more forgotten figure but swingley has a
close relationship with him he's writing
he writing two figures who are spread
across the German cities who were become
closely connected to him through this
bond of friendship friendship is in a
very important idea for swingley and
letter writing for him was an expression
of the bond between certain people and
that bond was not just spiritual but it
was one of almost familial and that's
what you see within this correspondence
is some of many of the figures are
completely forgotten and no but swingley
cultivated these relationships and you
see in return that he was frequently
being asked for advice one of the things
he was a it's almost a kind of agony
aunt of the of the Reformation he's
constantly being solicited for advice on
a whole range of questions and that that
you know and and his attempts to answer
these very often very practical issues
bring out I think concerns that we don't
find in any invisible area so what a
wonderful experience that must have been
for you to be able to read his letters
yes it was there anything that in
reading that really surprised you or
something that you completely did not
expect to find what I what one ways that
I was completely surprised is that in
his own writings swingley doesn't often
talk about himself if you look at Luther
Luther's writings are full of his own
experiences you get very much a picture
of this man who loved to drink beer who
loved his family who who thought about
the world very much in terms of his own
experiences so Luther's very present in
his writings swingley has very little
about it we we know very little about
his conversion experience we hope parts
of his early life we know nothing of
because he chose never to write about
them but what the letters do is help us
to fill in a lot of the gaps and I think
the fact that people have not really
looked at them has meant that we've seen
him as this slightly one-dimensional
figure what surprises me he talks about
his his love of music he talks about his
love of laughter he often will share a
joke which may not seem to us to be
hilariously funny but it shows that he
had a real sense of humor he talks about
as I say both about friendship but he
talks about his own experiences and it's
through the letters that as I say he
really comes comes to life in a way that
I think people have not really
appreciated right he does he does his
own anger a whole range of emotions that
we don't associate with these reformers
are very much there in his life he talks
about it tells a story at one point
where there was an attempt to abduct him
from his house but from his opponents by
his opponents they came to the door
pretending to be a messenger and only by
the work of one of the English domestic
staff did they recognize that these
people were actually there to try to
take swingley as a hostage he was
constantly threatened by violence there
was graffiti on the walls like he was a
highly controversial figure so what went
wrong basically what were the air what
went wrong was that
swingley had this idea that the swiss
weren't elect people that God like the
ancient Israelites God had chosen this
was he was a deep patriot and he
believed that the Swiss people this
these mountain people rustic that were
not aristocrats that were they had no
king they were they had this tradition
of vaguely speaking democracy where
communities would decide from these for
him were the great virtues of the
of his own people and he believed that
because God had chosen them because they
were the elect that the true religion
would naturally spread quickly that they
would embrace this that they would throw
off superstition they would throw off
the priestly class of the old medieval
church but he was desperately
disappointed because they they did not
they didn't and the powerful Catholic
forces remained within Swiss lands who
were opposing him and sought his own
execution and sought to crush what was
happening in the city of Zurich and that
moved swingley increasingly to an idea
that the gospel was going to have to be
spread by force which was quite a turn
in his thinking somewhere he had started
out so talk a little bit about that yes
I think this is being for me one of the
chief challenges in writing this book is
to see it's a relatively short period he
arrives in the city of Zurich in 1519 as
a Catholic priest and just over 12 years
later he's dead Wow so I mean it's
really only from 1519 to 1531 Luther
story spreads out over decades
Calvin's story spreads out over decades
swingley story is actually a very short
and an incredibly intense period of and
it's also a time of enormous conflict
and it's that I think it's as we spoke
about before it was that sense that the
the forces arrayed against him of the
Catholic Church were so strong that he
moved towards this idea that if the
people were to be liberated that the
temporal authorities were going to have
to draw the sword and to engage in what
we would see as a kind of form of
religious coercion forced people into
allowing the gospel to be preached and
you can see in this period of 15 25 26
swingley becoming more aggressive and
thinking about ways in which the
Reformation is going to have to be
spread by force so in his letters you
can you can see it coming where he's
becoming you know more and more
embracing the
that he had one shun yes did it ever did
he ever express any doubt in his letters
about wanting to use violence to have
things turn mourn yes I mean that's a
really interesting point he he saw
himself as loser did as a prophet who'd
been chosen by God swingley had a strong
sense of his own prophetic calling he
knew that there were many who opposed
him even in the city of Zurich where he
was he was never a completely dominant
figure he was an extraordinary
controversial one and at many points he
thought he was going to be thrown out of
the city he was going to be a prophet
who was not honored in his own land he
was doing so he knew that he was in a
kind of life-and-death struggle through
the whole time that he was there but he
as far as I can see he never lost faith
or never lost his vision that something
divine was taking place that he had been
called to this prophetic renewal of the
church but also a prophetic renewal of
his country the two were seen together I
don't think he ever lost that doubt and
I think he regretted that it led to war
there's no doubt about that but he
believed in the end he had to embrace it
and so he rides out from the city of
Zurich in 1531 in October armed and you
know enters into a conflict it was a bit
of a botched battle but in fact in the
middle of the night he struck down and
and killed but he's wearing armor he
simply had embraced the idea of a
military expansion of this and I've not
found any sense I can trace the
development of it but I don't see any
notion of a kind of self doubt about I
think he was highly convicted that this
was what he had today so ultimately what
do you think
Sweeney's legacy is yeah or should be
yes I mean although he has been this
relatively overshadowed figure I think
and what I hope to show is that many of
the core
arguments about swing about the
Reformation emerge in these early years
when swingley is the preeminent figure
amongst the Reformed Church this is
debate with the so-called anabaptists
about whether there should be at the
church should be in a relationship with
temporal authority or whether the two
should be separated it's a debate about
sacraments swingley is many ways the
initiator of what we would call
covenantal theology that there is a
covenant between God and God's people
that idea becomes incredibly powerful
for Calvinism for Puritanism and Beyond
and remains in our worlds still an idea
that is shared by many
so he's his legacy although people
wouldn't know to attribute it to him is
many of the key ideas that will form
later the Calvinism Puritanism and a
whole sir school of Protestant thought
which in its many many different forms
but he those key ideas really take shape
in the early 15 20s when he is the the
major figure okay well thank you so much
for being here today and sharing some of
your work thank you very much okay for
more information about Professor Gordon
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you